well i'm rolling in the deep
behind the knot
all right just have fun up there and
again
all that they are just as a reference
and everything
video wise is added in post sweeney's
doing a lot of like fun freeing and i'm
now remember there'll be some editing
if you're unsure of anything don't worry
it'll come out
[Music]
conor o'brien here for another edition
of behind the nonsense uh where i get a
chance to talk about some of my favorite
comedy bits i'm putting favorite in
quotes because uh these were not
selected by me with the help
of some of the people who helped make
them happen and today i'm sitting here
with andy richter i'm i'm so glad that
you said that right yeah i was afraid
you'd mispronounce it for six years on
the year i called you andy richter yeah
yeah yeah remember that i just thought
it was an affectation i thought you were
trying to be classy i was for a while
that was yeah that's when i had a
monocle first three years of the show
andy richter was my sidekick no we're
gonna just look back at some of these um
moments from the show and then tell you
sort of what was going on give you a
little insight into our sick process
uh if you can call it that um if we
could remember if we can remember yeah i
can i am stunned at how many clips i see
where i have no memory
and i would swear before a jury that
never happened and then they show me the
clip we just saw one the other night it
was a bit where you get stabbed and then
you bled about a gallon of blood live on
stage on the show
no recollection well i have no
recollection because i lost all that
blood oh right of course
all that all that corn syrup that
normally keeps you going
but anyway one of the things we're going
to do is take a look at something we
call scraps we would show these on the
show occasionally and these were a fan
favorite because uh this is moments from
rehearsal and you get to see how
terribly we dress you get to see us
without makeup you get to see us uh when
the show is coming up in an hour and
we're tense
and when i say we're tense i'm tense you
never gave a [ __ ]
and it's the secret to my
success exactly so let's start with this
scrap let's take a look and then we'll
talk it down
well uh welcome back everybody i hope
you had a
nice thanksgiving
[Applause]
time with your families and and loved
ones what with turkey and all
probably a real letdown from being
around you and me yeah
[ __ ] relatives
it's tough when you get used to this
kind of repartee
to go sit with real people yeah
my sister-in-law's house went to your
sister a bunch of people i didn't know
is that true oh but they were in show
business none of them what
none of them
but they had great wealth yes
some of them would seem to be doing just
fine but in that colorado way
[Laughter]
nice fleece
you're saying they weren't in show
business no and not all of them were
well to do
some no some of them were downright poor
they don't understand the struggle
i went to the isle of celebrities oh
really yes we had a wonderful time i was
there with maude adams
dietrich spader's brother hans
[Laughter]
justine bateman
[Laughter]
shaquille o'neal's lawyer
really yes
only the best
celebrity island
it's north of nova scotia
it's freezing yes
freezing it's on the rocky skulls
[Laughter]
you have to get your own food
muscles and clam
mussels and clams
okay what i see when i look at that is i
see a man who does not want to rehearse
the sketch that we're supposed to
rehearse
and you instead of getting me to
rehearse it you got your phone out yeah
and you don't care
and
that enables me to not care even more
right and then um
we go into one of our
classic riffs
where uh we're out of touch completely
out of touch we assume everyone's a
celebrity and everyone's wealthy yes yes
the because um we're so humble that's
the joke
that we're so humble and approachable
and there's absolutely no separation
between us and the people that work here
those people also i know that when you
when i say up front we're just back uh
from thanksgiving i hope you all had a
good time or something yeah it was we
were away for a while but we're just
back and
those are the hardest shows when you
show up at a rehearsal in a concrete box
and everyone's just back from a holiday
and there's no energy in the studio and
everybody's still kind of hung over on
gravy and wine you
that's the energy i'm working off of i'm
picking that up in the room
and uh deciding to just
tank rehearsal yeah and it's also kind
of like there's a production meeting or
so i've heard uh earlier in the morning
and then but this is kind of where
you're addressing
the because people have it on in there i
haven't yeah i haven't seen everybody
seen everybody this is me saying uh
trying to say welcome back and i hope
you had a good time but of course i
can't do that because i can't be a
sincere human being so i have to be a
character who's like well
good time with your loved ones yeah yeah
all right let's take a look at another
scrap and uh find out more about how it
all works behind the scenes
i think mr met is the worst
single worst yeah
it looks like a botched experiment yeah
it really does
it looks like something that needs to be
it looks like it's saying please kill
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
nothing those homer's over the wall
there's a red sock song that's awful
it was really yeah yeah
and it had a banjo it's always a
banjo i think there was one that was
literally like that like
yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
go down the 405.
someone's crowding me a little bit
oh man
oh what i wouldn't give to have that
oh you could get that done i could get
that done hello tesla tesla
i have a quick request
oh tesla
i know i'm like the 50th to ask today
can i get call your strengths
you just did it automatically
thank you
thank you elon elon's the best
funny crap i just called
an update what's that can be stew come
out the back
already is already done
only 40 000 sure
charge it to whoever pays for these
things
today after ordering
corn chowder to come out the back of his
tesla
there's a lot to unpack here uh first of
all there's a twilight zone where a kid
um in a family has ultimate power and
he's played by billy mummy and he
terrifies the whole family because he
can make whatever he wants to happen
happen that's kind of what it's like to
have one of these shows you sit there at
your desk and you have an idea and
you'll just reference a song mr met or i
will and then immediately it starts yeah
somebody's on a computer looking it up
yeah and they're bringing it out now
people watching this right now or yeah
it's called an iphone [ __ ]
but it is kind of funny they can project
it so
we would call up stuff and either the
video would come up
or the music would come up instantly and
then we would go off on these wild jags
like that uh where we're just talking
[ __ ] none of that had anything to do
with the show i love the quick shot of
jeff ross in there who's always just
waiting for this madness right right
right because we have a show to do and
he's not having it right he's just like
can we get done with this yeah but no
you and i are very happy with uh our
little riff and then we find the tesla
component of it yeah and that's the best
part of our day usually yeah that's the
part where people sometimes afterwards
go that should be the show which is so
annoying because if we did make that the
show you wouldn't really like it yeah
you wouldn't i promise you you would not
but yeah yeah there's always someone
afterwards
uh on the crew or on the staff or
someone in the back who's even part of
the show who's just like i saw that in
rehearsal with the tesla with the
glasses
that's the show yeah not the [ __ ] you're
doing that's it and they act like the
audience a week later wouldn't just be
jeff ross
anyway that was a lot of fun yeah it's a
little window into how much fun you can
have at rehearsal yeah let's move on and
look at some other things oh sweeney
we've heard enough andy
fat
santa hung out with jeffrey epstein in
the 90s okay don't don't do that look at
this picture conan see
jeffrey epstein with donald trump and
someone else who was torn out well i
tracked down the real picture i got the
missing piece right here
oh what a silly story wasn't that silly
coated
let's stop let's stop i mean we get the
idea it's okay honey daisy i think i
have been trained to attack a bad ending
okay it's okay he says it daisy said
daisy said it's okay it's okay no i know
it's daisy it's okay
i just talked to you earlier
honey honey honey i think you should go
sweetie
sweetie it's okay
it's okay baby it's okay
okay this i remember
well because
uh the sketch up to that point i've been
going for a while the sketch isn't going
well you brought your dog by and then
the actor who plays santa comes out your
dog starts bugging santa and then i say
oh
the dog barks at bad endings yeah yeah i
don't think what you see here is that i
kept going for a while about
a dog trained to detect a lazy writer
uh
coming up with a quick corny idea to end
the sketch and then once i sink my teeth
into something like that where i can go
after the writers and in a i think a
joyous way because god knows i love them
um i'm i'm i'm as happy
as a clam in a clam boat i'm so happy so
i think that went on for a while you
also get to see there my uh style i'm a
guitarist who also flies a b-52 fighter
oh i think we're being joined right now
by by jose arroyo did you help write
this sketch jose no i didn't help write
it i wrote it
and uh all by yourself
yeah you were saying oh it was a lazy
ending and stuff how can you say it got
the best possible chance
when a dog
raced in
and attacked the actor that we cast i
don't know it just felt like it didn't
get better did you think did you think
be honest so you think that the whole
sketch could have been redeemed by santa
coming out and chloroforming andy you
think that could have saved nine minutes
of previous sketch that had given us no
laughter it only felt like nine minutes
he's hated my dog since that day and
guess what the dog was here and did not
bark at that hilarious comment that's
right that jose
made so the dog does know the difference
between a funny ending right and that
travesty
we all witnessed that was for me though
aside from comedy wise that was like a
very reassuring day for me i know that
like if i ever get chloroform my dog
will be upset by no you
if you ever get chloroformed by santa
your dog will say oh anyone else your
dog doesn't give a [ __ ] i used to bring
i used to bring her to rehearsal but i
had to stop because twice where conan
stands on his mark was there was a rug
and she twice peed on that rug yeah she
came up onto the stage smelled that rug
and peed on it has never peed inside
anywhere else no that's never ever ever
that's a dog marking its territory
[Music]
oh i thought i was doing some funny
stuff there and
the secretary came running yeah no i
guess you decided it was over we were
getting into some people no no wait till
the rifts are done you can come in
there's plenty of time no i mean we're
done with this one you cut it off it's
over oh please i need to focus i need to
focus to remember the good times this is
awful
let's never do this again